oh The House Always Wins especially if
it's the Grammy house welcome to
Entertainment Tonight everybody I think
the saying goes what happens in Vegas
happens on E.T hello because we were the
only show backstage with the winners
moments after they nabbed Grammy gold
and for Bruno Mars and Anderson pack
they placed all their bets on a silk
Sonic Sweep come on
Sonic thank you guys so much Vegas we
in the industry we call that a clean
Suite
silk Sonic hit the Vegas Jackpot the duo
swept all four Grammy Awards despite
Anderson's on stage zipper malfunction
[Applause]
they also set the tone for the Night
opening the show with a spectacular Sin
City theme performance of 777.
and from a sweet to a shutout
zero out of five times how many grams I
wanna land but little Nas X took it in
stride what can you tell us about this
performance I'm going to eat the
performance up
[Music]
that medley included three outfit
changes which brought the grand total to
five
and seven is the lucky number that makes
up BTS
tonight's performance describe it in
three words
well we'll better describe it in motion
goes like this
the K-pop phenoms delivered Jungkook was
lowered to the stage as the group
Channel their inner James Bond
at one point j-hope did have a slight
stumble up the stairs but as the song
goes his recovery was smooth stars like
Lady Gaga Olivia Rodrigo make the
stallion John Legend with Chrissy Teigen
and daughter Luna were all caught in the
K-pop frenzy what I really wanna know is
you said
you said I'm Gonna Go My Way Lenny
Kravitz was the big surprise guest
during hers next level medley
[Applause]
[Music]
I watched Lenny growing up I'd like
study literally studied all his videos
of his performances and I he's one of
the reasons why I even wanted to play
guitar
back on the carpet I broke the news
about her pre-show Grammy win so you you
come here and you already win it I'm
wait what did I win I firm now you have
won best oh my God yes r b traditional
performance
oh my gosh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Billy eilish didn't take home a Grammy
but she wins for her incredible
performance rocking out in the rain
singing happier than ever Billy paid
tribute to Foo Fighters drummer Taylor
Hawkins wearing a t-shirt with his image
on it Foo Fighters the Foo Fighters won
all three of their nominated categories
but did not attend ET has learned that
instead Dave Grohl had a gathering at
his house Taylor's Widow Allison and
their two daughters were there
sour Olivia Rodrigo newcomer Olivia
Rodrigo made her Grammy's debut winning
three of her seven nominations how's it
feel congratulations oh my gosh thank
you I'm over the moon it's crazy I can't
even process it how do you celebrate
tonight
um I'm going with my friends it'll be
fun they all came to Vegas to support so
I'm gonna go hang out with them
[Music]
the 19 year old revved up the award show
with driver's license it's crazy I've
just watched the Grammys religiously
since I was so young and just to be here
and perform up on that stage is just
such an honor Olivia's Best New Artist
win was introduced by Dua Lipa and Meg
the stallion not just all my look they
had a wild Diva 20 moment you know what
let's do this
a tribute to this Infamous 1998
throwback with Whitney Houston and
Mariah Carey you look good you look very
good and there was another Deja Vu
moment backstage Olivia looked stunned
after she dropped one of her Grammys on
the red carpet fans quickly pointed out
the similarities to Taylor Swift back in
2010 when she dropped one of her four
Awards also memorable Doja cat racing
from the bathroom nearly missing
accepting her Award with sizza I had so
much champagne I have never bacon
such a fast
in my whole life
a woman ran into the bathroom and that
God God I don't remember her name but
she she grabbed me by my wrist yanked me
out and I was like I've never been
pulled so strongly in my life I got to
the stage I like to downplay but this is
a
deal
the singer who broke down in tears
tweeted last week she was quitting the
music business you had Twitter Ablaze
you had social media blades you had our
Newsroom Blaze with the news that Doja
grat is quitting music that can't happen
uh
you will be going out on tour correct
yes I will yes what he's trying to say
is tell everybody it's gonna happen yes
North America I'm coming
and only ET has this adorable moment
that's Jon Batista's nephew dancing for
Doja cat backstage
[Music]
John was mesmerizing last night decked
out in Dolce Gabbana for his joyous
performance of Freedom we are John
Baptiste
the 35 year old won five Grammys and
told me backstage about his secret
marriage to author sulaika Jawad she's
undergoing chemotherapy treatments for
her second battle with cancer they've
been together for eight years this is
the thing about life you have to go with
the moment you have to know when it's
the time to do something and that's what
we did we did it got married boom boom
last night was also about the anything
but low-key couples
check out Haley Bieber singing along as
hubby Justin performed in leather pants
giving some friends fans Ross Geller
vibes from kissing her neck to
Whispering I love you the pair got super
close just three weeks after Haley
revealed she cheated death with a blood
clot in her brain
after arriving solo winner Lady Gaga
grooved along to the Biebs with her man
Michael Polanski by her side the Grammys
unofficial fan girl also posed with
Keith Urban who was without wife Nicole
Kidman but he gave her this sweet shout
out hi baby girl I'll be home very soon
winning for gospel album I feel like
I've just been super emotional all night
so exciting to have new music and
there's a lot more to come and you
arrived looking like country royalty
winner Carrie Underwood got a kiss and a
standino from adoring hubby Mike Fisher
their two boys were not far away my kids
are actually in my hotel room right now
and they're probably going to wake me up
at Lord knows what time in the morning
because that's what they've been doing
ever since they got here they better be
in bed
Mom and Daddy get to have a date night
absolutely we are having fun from Marin
Morris and Ryan Hurd to Mickey Guyton
and Grant Savoy plenty of grammy couples
made it parents night out I know you're
ready for more I am I'm ready for more
yeah bring it on I want baby after baby
Lord Lord you know
a beaming Kourtney Kardashian cheered on
fiance Travis Barker after arriving hand
in hand briefly ditching their black
shades for their version of a kiss which
continued inside bestie Addison Ray
copied them yep Grammy PDA and love was
everywhere he melted me he melted me
somebody had to do it right exactly also
on the carpet Chris Stapleton and his
wife Morgan he stole a hug from her on
his way to the stage to accept best
country album I'm a dad of five
and uh today is my Twin's birthday
they're four years old so I thank you we
had a party yesterday we had an Elvis
impersonator to show up for that but
that was nice they're big Elvis fans so
I think their hearts about jumped out of
their chest because we've told them that
Elvis is not alive anymore
fellow country artists Brothers Osborne
closed out the show and before that they
took home their first ever Grammy for
Best country duo or group performance
have you talked to your family yet we
haven't had a chance to talk to anybody
pull up where's your phone we got you on
ET right now Mom you don't need thank
you mom mama they won how proud are you
I'm very proud I love my boys I mean
they are so talented I think that Grammy
is long overdue by the way oh that's
what I'm talking about another proud
mama Valerie Bertinelli she was by her
son Wolfie's side on the carpet he was
nominated for his song distance
remembering his late father Eddie Van
Halen thinking about what this would
mean to your dad he would be losing his
mind
but also at the same time he'd be like
duh because that's how much he believed
in me you know or I see you already
already I know it's an emotional it is
really emotional she went back to the
room she it was taking up so much space
she didn't want to do interviews too she
looked like a dream she looked like a
princess she's my dream inside the Las
Vegas venue Chrissy changed into her
second dress of the night and brought
two little dates with her Luna and Miles
watched daddy John perform a tribute for
Ukraine let peace rush in they have a
dream of them living and free free to
thank you on the dream stage president
zielinski made a surprise appearance
giving a powerful speech before the
performance which included poet lubic
yamshuk who fled Ukraine just days ago
shoot and protect my husband my parents
my child and my motherland to be here
it's mean to have this incredible
support of Americans and this is like
unreal for me
and it is very real because she still
has family in the Ukraine right now that
was an incredible moment John Legend
always gives us those moments
foreign